many productions but on to the last one
so we will have this week two types of
talks we let the fellow talks as a mr.
already mentioned and the main part of
the program is their tutorials in which
our speakers will introduce the
mathematics needed for a doing the kind
of applications that we are interested
in and the other talks will be on the
applications themselves okay I guess our
first speaker will be V not by unit an
and will tell us about the mathematics
of practices okay so thanks al for the
for the introduction and thanks Donald
guy Shafi al everyone for putting this
this workshop together and santim thank
you so small it's great to see all of
you here as Alistair said this is a
certain icebreaker so let's just have a
party together
you know a party where you ask me
questions and I answer right it's a
one-way communication strange kind of
party so okay so the goal of this talk
is to sort of as an introduction to the
mathematics of lattices in particular
the mathematics of lattices as it
pertains to cryptographic users so I'll
be heavily biased towards the use of
lattices and cryptography so the thing
is a you know as most of you know over
the last you know seven eight years
there has been a real explosion of so
the use of lattices in cryptography will
reuse it to construct all kinds of you
know strange you know interesting
cryptographic objects but to tell you
the truth really all these uses have to
travel for you they're you know 100
different cryptographic primitives that
you can build from lattices but all
these rely on a small set of core
techniques I would say four maybe five
core tech
so my goal and today's talk is to tell
you what these core techniques someone
they'll sleep happy for if I get through
you know if it's not completely zero
knowledge you know I get through let's
say one or two do you okay so that's ago
so it's let's get started right from the
beginning lattices what are lattice this
is a lot of a lattice the
two-dimensional lattice and what is a
lot is it's a I give you n linearly
independent vectors in RN in fact for
today all these vectors will be integer
vectors for the moment I didn't want to
deal with issues of rounding you know
precision so on and so forth
so I give you n vectors from Z to the
end and you take all integer linear
combinations of these vectors that gives
you a lot is and that is that here you
have B 1 and B 2 you take all linear
coming in teacher combinations you get
things like you know me 1 plus me to be
1 minus 2 B 2 he can keep going right
that gives you a infinite set of vectors
that's a lot is this thing about
lattices I mean and that really is there
is a birth defects or hardness you know
cryptography based on lattices is that
the same lattice can be generated many
different ways so this is a basis for
that for the lattice it's a little bit
of four different bases from what I
showed you already before right so you
take all integer combinations of b1 and
b2 you get this lattice and this is of a
blue basis this is a good basis so why
is it a good basis because these vectors
are short essentially as short as they
can be if you look at it you can now you
can generate the same lattice is also
generated by other bases this is an
example this is a pretty terrible basis
right it is long vectors they were
skewed it close to each other so on and
so forth right so that's a bad basis and
we'll see what is the point of you know
that that's very nice right good and
your bad you know it's not even
particularly well-defined at this point
I mean where is the line right we will
see what is the point of these good and
bad bases as we go along but just
remember that there are these creatures
so let me ask you something what about
this basis is a good or bad what do you
think goodish you know that says it's a
good one what do you think you know it's
supposed to be a party you know what you
know you know one doesn't make a party
yes it's not it's not a basis it's not a
basic excellent right because you know
if you look at it this guy cannot be
generated that's integer linear
combination of these two guys a good way
to see what is not a basis is you draw
the parallelogram generated by these two
vectors that is this look at you know
see if there is a lattice vector inside
if there is one there's no hope of
generating that kind as an integer
linear combination that's that right so
that this this is not a basis thank you
very much okay so that's that's great
there is a there are a lot of
interesting quantities related to
lattices that the mathematicians are
interested in I'll talk about just one
of those today and that will sort of
translate the computation that will
translate to cryptography right that's
so the source of all cryptography okay
good so what is this problem a you know
you know the quantity of interest in
lattices is the length of the shortest
vector in the lattice of course it has
to be nonzero vector because zero is
always a lattice vector right doesn't
make any sense
shortest nonzero vector I call that
lambda one right this is a fundamental
quantity of interest in lattices and you
know the the the gentleman there anyone
know who that is the pop quiz you know I
mean it looks like any other dude with
the mustache but you know but he is a
very eminent mathematician is Hermann
Minkowski who really pioneered many of
the theorems and mathematics of lattices
so he was interested in this quantity
you know he proved various bounds on how
long the shortest vector can be so it
says you know if the lattice is it's
dense in the sense that if you look at
the the volume
the parallelepiped you can bound the
length of the shortest vector as a
function of this cell this number okay
so on and so forth very nice theorems
and we will only this is as much as I'm
going to say about about Minkowski I'll
move on to sort of problems computation
and so on and so forth so we're not just
happy with knowing that there is a short
vector in the lattice we want to find it
right that's what we do computer
scientists right you want to find it and
what that is the shortest vector problem
now this I'll give you a basis and this
basis has no bounds I mean it is an
arbitrary basis of the lattice it could
be a bad basis probably no all right a
good basis contains short vector so not
particularly interesting right I give
you an arbitrary basis the question is
can you find the shortest vector in the
last whether this this creature is
actually well-defined there is a notion
of shortest vector because this is a
discrete set because otherwise you know
what is you know in our what is the
shortest right so well defined can you
find it that's the question right this
is believed to be a very very hard
question lots of people have worked on
it this is sort of the source affair of
cryptography so okay example you know
you draw a ball around the origin
expanded expanded expanded till you hit
a lattice point that is a shorter
specter okay okay so you know we if we
cannot solve something we are you know
cannot throw the dart and it hits on
there we really draw that you know the
target right that's the approximate to
short a strike to a problem and say well
you know I don't want the exact shorter
specter I want something that is at most
five times a vector that whose length is
at most five times the length of the
shortest writer okay so that's the
approximate short distraction problem
alfe approximation alpha could actually
be a function of the dimension oh you
know that's the approximate version of
the shortest vector problem one more
thing at all I'll get going and that is
a different problem called the shortest
independent vectors problem okay so what
is this what is this creature
well look we found the shortest vector
in the lattice and that is this guy
good question what is the second
shortest rector in the lattice I mean
I'm not happy with one give me the
second what would that be
I think about it think about it think
about it right I say well look this guy
is the second shortest rector Oh
beautiful right that's not an
interesting second shortest vector the
interesting second shortest vector is
one that is linearly independent from
the first shortest vector and that is as
it turns out this guy which is a little
bit longer than the than the first one
okay more generally I can define these
quantities lambda 1 which is the length
of the shortest vector lambda 2 lambda 3
blah blah blah up to lambda n which is
the length of the end shorter segment
what does that mean I take a ball around
the origin
I keep expanding and expanding expanding
it when I hit the lattice point I know
that is a short distractor it's the
length of the shortest writer expanding
it expanding expanding it what is the
minimum radius by which I'll hit I'll
contain and linearly independent lattice
vectors the minimum radius that contains
n linearly independent shortest vectors
and that's called lambda n that's again
a fundamental quantity in the study of
lattices lambda lambda two is two
dimensions right lambda two is is this
number okay so the shortest independent
vectors problem is given a basis of the
lattice again point n vectors not one
but n vectors each of whose length is at
most London that's the shortest
independent vectors problem if you think
about it a little bit they don't want to
dwell on this point too much but these
two are distinct problems we solve one
doesn't mean that you solve the other
right you see you see why I do one on
the one hand I'm asking you to find the
shortest vector in the lattice on the
other hand I'm asking you to find many
and instead of one but they all can be
as large as lambda n right it may not
contain a vector of length lambda one
distinct problems both interesting
and good so that's that's as much as I'm
gonna say but how problems okay so once
you have problems you wanna see what
does it take to solve them you know an
approximate exact how much time so on
and so forth so this is my one slide
summary of about you know hundred years
of work I suppose on laddus algorithms
and complexity I'm doing a terrible
injustice
you know pardon me but this is all this
is as much time as I'm gonna get
okay this is really like two semesters
worth of you know stuff
what slate okay so we can ask so what is
this line this is a really the
approximation factor right you start
from left to the right the approximation
factor increases the one is exact SVP
and what is what do we know about it
well it turns out that you go back all
the way to Euclid right you know
everything good comes from the Greeks
yes I mean you've got a trace back you
so you Clint right
Euclid gave us short a structure
algorithm in one dimension okay and what
is you know let me tell you a writer so
what is here is a one-dimensional are is
generated by two numbers six and eight
what is the shortest factor in it what
is what does it mean six and eight all
integer linear combinations of six and
eight that generates Alaris what is the
shortest factor in it - indeed indeed -
right what is - two is the GCD of six
and eight yes
so GCD is really the shortest vector
problem one in one dimension so and then
it took about eighteen hundred years and
before Gauss he said well two dimensions
I can still do it okay that already took
more ideas more work just Euclid right
then it took more and more and more time
and the best best algorithm we know at
this point and the work is still ongoing
on this on this problem is very exciting
work already in stock this year there is
a new better shortest vector algorithm
but the best time we know that this will
and so on and it stood at the end okay
sudhi the end is actually exactly that
right no to the end okay good to the end
is the best time we know this
so just picky yes well zero makes the
problem uninteresting right I mean I can
always tell you zero it's better but my
not really so so my definition of the
shorter structural problem excludes zero
right way so the definition of lambda
one is there you know what is the
shortest nonzero vector right so yeah so
I'm gonna
I like zero but I mean we are Indians
right I mean we are we're very proud of
our zeroes but you know for now you know
it's a let's kind of leave it aside so
all right so so lots of work is still
ongoing
very exciting area but the best known
algorithm Bronston to the end time
that's for exact how about approximate
once you sort of increase these of the
approximation factor all the way let's
say to 2 to the N over 2 right to the
end about to the end this is the
groundbreaking amazing work of lenss
tall and strong lavash who showed that
you can in polynomial time you can find
a vector whose length is 2 to the N over
2 times the shortest vector the length
of the shortest rector of the lattice
all right this is this might sound you
know pointless to you only 2 to the N I
can do everything entire time to the end
right I mean what is what is there to do
the point is this approximation factor
does not depend it only depends on the
dimension it does not depend on the
length of the you know basis L to the
bit length to the basis which could
actually be of the input basis which
could actually be very long you're
saying I don't really care right I can
get an approximation factor that depends
only on the dimension some beautiful
beautiful work you can improve this a
little bit to whatever this number is
and log blog over log that's the
best-known in fact you can interpolate
between these two extremes and you can
get 2 to the K approximation in between
in 2 to the about n over K time tilde
hides log factors
and in fact the interesting thing is
this is the best-known even if you have
quantum computers right I mean quantum
computers don't seem to you know achieve
any speed-up over classical algorithms
it's as far as we know I think's could
change like you know tonight for
instance but as of now as of now as as
far as I know this is the best album
okay so so two extremes polynomial time
two to the N and to the an approximation
and to the end time one approximation
exact
okay so let's algorithms one could ask
about the complexity of these questions
right I mean so you know all these
problems np-hard
right I mean in fact you know more or
precisely are the decision versions of
these problems np-hard right and that it
turns out is the case so in the exact
shortest factor but I didn't I didn't
say something very important which is
you know what does it mean short I mean
I didn't mean sort what does it mean
when I have to define a norm right and
we'll talk about Euclidean norm all
through this this talk and things could
change depending on which normal I'm
talking about but Euclid right good for
me so the exact shot a structure problem
is np-hard ten something that's again a
major sort of groundbreaking result of
fight I back in the nineties and so is
it and the NP hardness sort of stays
even if you sort of increase the
approximation factor I mean all the way
up to something like 2 to the log n to
the 1 minus epsilon what is that
creature it's smaller than any
polynomial but it's very very close to
polynomial right right it's a not n to
the point zero zero zero zero zero one
but smaller than that but very close and
that is and be hard it's sort of np-hard
under randomized reductions so on and so
forth but let's not worry why okay so
that's what we know what the complexity
okay so Poli time I can do two to the
end 2 to the log n to the 1 minus
epsilon is np-hard really sort of
exciting for us for cryptographers
development came in 1996 with aitai
discovering a way to construct one-way
functions the most basic the most kind
of structure less the most primordial
you know cryptographic parameters that
you can think of starting from the
hardness of approximating the shortest
vector to within a factor of n that's
what you did so beautiful is the
landmark result really I mean we exist I
mean I exist because so far because so
so look at this I mean there is a it's a
little bit of a conundrum here right so
this cryptography photography needs to
assume that an approximate shorter
Spectre is hard that's the best we know
at this point in fact I - I started from
something like n to the 6 or n to the
8th I'm not quite sure exactly what but
the later work of me Chandra gave
beautiful work again
reduce this approximation factor to n
right so it's better to sort base
cryptography on smaller and smaller
approximation factors as it gets harder
and harder it's better to move left so
that's what good choice that's what the
NP hardness regime is right so this is
this amazing amazing open question in
cryptography which is can you build any
kind of cryptography from NP hardness
right so let's say if you don't know it
you should know it and if you are not
working on it you should work on it
right that's that's how important this
is and so so so you know if I wasn't
doing crypto back then but I understand
the one of the reasons people were so
excited about large space cryptography
is that it gave us potentially one way
to base cryptography on NP hardness
right if you could remove this left left
left left remove this right right right
right
once they intersect you're done right
that's what we want unfortunately life
doesn't come so easy yes so
unfortunately it turns out that an
approximating the shortest vector
is an NP convict and B intersect going
people say said this guy wants the
approximation factor is very important
in deciding whether this problem has
structure or not right less than 2 to
the log n to the 1 minus epsilon it
doesn't have any structure because it's
as hard as that right and once you pass
something like end you start getting
structure this is the result of Banasik
back in 93 and this uses something
called you know do a lot is this and
they called transference theorems I
won't get into it too much but you
should say period and and beautiful
beautiful result so it says I can
certify that a lattice and does not have
a particularly short vector in NP I can
give you a witness that tells you your
act I mean hard how do you do that
right bizarre but you can do it okay
that's an P coin P you can extend this a
little bit further beautiful results
again our on oven - I gave extended this
all the way to square root N and if you
move a little bit further square root of
n over log n this problem is in Co am
not quite Co MP but it's only attractive
version of a point B that's where it
stood and what does what consequence is
it that a problem is in NP intersect
coin P or NP intersect Co am the point
is that you know above this approach
this approximation factor and above
these problems gap is VP with this
approximation factor it's unlikely to be
np-hard because if it is np-hard then
you know polynomial hierarchy comes
collapsing down alright so so in a sense
this sort of dashes all hope one would
think
but to take this with the pinch of salt
that you can base cryptography on on NP
hardness not yet indeed excellent you
you think right okay good so so this
says you cannot move the right point
beyond this boundary
who says you cannot move the blue point
to left or the boundary excellent please
work on it
okay so this is incredibly important as
a question yes so we don't have any
negative results no no not as far as I
know so that is the algorithms and
complexity slide the only algorithm
superproxy slide I have so okay so the
rest of the talk I'm going to just
ignore you know all the centuries of
work on algorithms in complexity I'm
going to just talk about the Couto
crypto part of it the crypto angle so
while a destructor this is a mandatory
slide that I have to you know put into
every talk that I give up what lattices
but you know let me do it anyway okay so
while lattices factoring breaks in fact
we know that discrete logarithms can be
solved in quasi-polynomial time on
certain fields right so why not discrete
logarithms in general why not factoring
in general okay that'll be my dream
situation right you will have to resort
to lattices eventually quantum
resistance as I said before quantum you
know your dad with factoring and
discrete logs and lattices so far they
stunts worst case harness this is this
is something that I'll get into in much
more detail in the rest of the talk
again there's a unique feature of light
space cryptography and again really tons
of applications mean that you'll hear
about today and tomorrow lots of things
that you can do that we know how to do
from lattices but not from other things
not to my knowledge maybe you can get
like a square root and speed out because
of growver type things but I don't know
any I don't even know that actually so
so what do I mean by worst case an
average case right so this is really one
of the core very important features of
of lattices you know worst case hardness
sir you know all I talked about in
complexity of lattices up to this point
was worst case hardness its worst case
Honda says there is one instance for
every algorithm there is one instance
where it fails possibly that's you know
that's really the safest thing to assume
right I mean that's what complexity
theorists assume where is in
cryptography you need more you need
average case hardness you need the
random incidents to be hard
we all know it and fortunately for
lattice problems worst case is equal to
average case so this is a very you know
broad strokes overstatement now I'll get
to the specifics in the rest of the talk
but you know you can you can get crypto
systems assuming the worst case hardness
of you know and approximating the
shortest writers for instance alright
this is not something that we know how
to do from any other sort of you know
mathematical object so hardness is good
average case hardness is even better but
we're not happy with that we want to go
from hardness to usefulness like what
can we do based on this average case
hardness and that is really the story of
of today and hopefully the next talk and
tomorrow right you can build many many
things from lattices and this is just a
incomplete list of things
cryptographic objects and citations can
do tons of things and believe it or not
I want to tell you about all of these
today in the next I don't know one half
hours the good thing about all these
like vast majority was you know
collection of these cryptographic
objects is that you can really serve
distill a few techniques large
techniques that enable you to build all
these things in one short
and these are the things so number one
this notion of this is average-case
heart problem called the short integer
solutions problem and it's cousin called
the inhomogeneous short integer
solutions problem which has an
unfortunate acronym that's number one
number two is the is the learning with
errors problem all right so these are
techniques that you know this gives you
that this gives you that the third is
and it's a notion of trapdoors for
lattices and how do you generate them
how do you use them right it's number
three number four even better right so
as you go down the list the objects
become harder and harder to construct
and more and more useful the last thing
that last sort of technique that I want
to tell you about is the notion of
punctured trapdoors
so we'll get to what all these things
mean in a bit but these are the four
really core things and if you know these
you are ready to go home and and do your
own lattice based crypto all right so so
that's that's the goal for today we'll
see how far we get I'll be very happy if
I get to
okay so before I tell you what I'm gonna
do
I also should tell you what I'm not
going to do lattices have been used in
crypt analysis well before they were
used in cryptography I'm not going to
talk about it beautiful beautiful works
in fact you can use lattices to break
versions so far as they look amazing
very beautiful work and I'm not going to
tell you about it not going to tell you
about special class of lattices collider
lattices although I think maybe Sundra
more shy we'll get to it there talks I
won't tell you about constructions of
several other cryptographic primitives
pseudo-random functions fully
homomorphic encryption which I will get
to multi linear maps which sunjin we'll
get to so not too unhappy that I'm not
gonna talk about it okay so so that's
that's that's that okay so now let's
actually get to the meat of fur thanks
okay so average-case heart problems
shut-ins just solutions so here is the
the problem okay so I give you a system
of equations and this is really
this is an underdetermined system of
equations right so you have three
variables R is a vector three variables
two equations right and I want you to
find a solution to it easy right we all
know
thank you very much cows you know you do
it right you do Gaussian elimination you
can find not just a solution but
essentially the subspace of all
solutions now let me change this problem
a tiny bit okay this is really the core
of hardness of a flattish problem so
what there are two types of lumps you
can define on lattices purely algebraic
problems you know like you know you know
decide if two bases generate the same
lattice you can do it you know you can
do it but once you introduce geometry
into the picture things start getting
that's when things start getting hard
I'm not saying all sort of geometric
problems and lattices are hard winter
that's where the hardness source of
hardness and strong okay so short is a
geometric notion can you find a short
Tower what do I mean by short let's say
you know an R which has zero one entries
for the moment right did you find this
more generally you could say you know an
hour where the l2 norm of are as small
as infinity norm so on and so forth
indeed thank you thank you non zero good
this turns out to be hard students have
to be insanely hard and I'll talk about
this further further further for the
next 20 minutes or so so it's just be a
little bit more precise the short
integer solutions problem is defined by
parameters n which is the number of
equations at the height of this matrix Q
is the field over which I work always
going to work over a finite field M is
the number of variables M is the number
of variables and it's a number of
equations Q's of any field and beta is a
bound on the how short right I mean what
do I mean by short I mean how short a
vector do I want as a solution
so I give you a matrix a of this nature
from n by M so this is an
underdetermined system of equations it's
always going to be a I don't know short
and a bit pudgy and you have to find
this shorter that's it a times R should
be zero so R is in the kernel of a in a
sense the point is that there are many
vectors in the kernel of a this is an
underdetermined system of equations I
want you to find a short one that's
that's what it is again
again when we talk about sort of many
norms what does it mean by short you
know short L infinity L 2 so on and so
forth I'm just going to talk about L 2
but really you know any norm any
reasonable normal you can think of you
know you can you can this problem is
still hard ok so this is the short
integer solutions problem so really the
way I mean you know once you look at it
you realize that you know in contrast to
something like factoring where which is
parameterized by self one number right
in and but you know something you
multiply the two we find the many
parameters here right and that is sort
of a you know an unfortunate sort of
team in cryptography but let's kind of
try to sort of at least isolate one of
these so merge two of these terms
together so really you know the Q and n
they don't really matter independently
all all I'm talking about is really the
group is that Q to the N right so I
could cast the short integer solutions
problem in a little bit more generality
as a generalized Esaias which says I
give you a bunch of group elements right
so so group elements here correspond two
vectors columns of the matrix before
what was the group there it was Z Q to
the N that Q to the N
I'll give you many numbers many group
elements and I want you to find the
short linear combination again a short
linear combination that sums to 0 over
the group so really Q an end they don't
matter separately
all that matters is a group which is
queue to the end the size of the group
reading just Q to the N so it's one way
to think about it right I don't know how
to whittle down any of the other terms
so I'm gonna I'm gonna really stop here
good so so when I yes so when I talk
about that Q to the end I'm assuming
that you know this is a full rank matrix
so you can you can generate all numbers
on the right hand side for zero it
doesn't quite matter but yeah but yes
indeed
okay so so so we'll go back so this is
you know this is just to give you some
context this generalize this we want to
talk about it ever again so you don't
have to remember it this is the problem
yes yes indeed and we'll get to it well
we'll get to so so you know so you more
broadly the question you're asking if
I'm right is this looks like you know
it's looks like a nice algebraic problem
what does it have to do with lattices I
mean so why is this a lattice problem
why what what is the relation we'll get
to it and exercise if you can figure it
out in the next i don't know like 20
minutes it's great this is really a
lattice problem this is really sis is a
short vector problem on on a certain
lattice well okay so maybe but but you
know what the moment you sort of fur
endow something with the norm are you
saying is because it's discrete discrete
is is a key thing right so so when i
said the group s is one generalized a
size i was working over a you know I
meant sort of a discrete group actually
met a discrete abelian group that
doesn't have to be right but you know
for the moment is just to give you some
context forget about generalization all
right let's just fix just focus on is
that Q to the end as our group right so
I give you a matrix and by M matrix
short and fat give me a vector in the
kernel in the right kernel of this
matrix which is small just smaller that
is what we'll talk about the next 20
minutes okay good excellent okay so the
first thing you ask is why did I come up
with this problem like what's the what's
the point what's the use for us as
cryptographers and so so one thing that
you can that you can get out of this
hardness of this problem already is is a
one-way function this was this was
essentially done by you know high tides
work in 96 I mean he came up with this
sis problem of why did he come up with
it he constructed a one-way function and
immediately after goal-directed was sir
and Holly we observed that the same
function is also collision-resistant
hash function even better under the same
assumption let's see how that how that
actually works this is the first piece
of crypto that I'm throwing at you so
you know it's okay so so what is our
function what is our collision resistant
hash function it's simply this function
so f that takes this input
it's parameterised by a matrix a so it's
a family of functions right parametrized
by random you know ace and that Q to the
N by M full rank matrices for the moment
takes as input an length M vector R and
outputs a times R mod Q so all all I'm
working with is over that Q all the
operations are over there that makes
sense so it's a linear function right I
mean it I mean what good can a linear
function be I mean linear functions are
worthless I mean we like them but
they're worthless cryptographic objects
if the point is that these are linear
functions whose domains are restricted
to be small sets vectors of small norm
and that's really what gives it hardness
that's what ice is is really if you
think about it
all right so this is a function is a
family functions my claim it's a
collision resistant
family of hash functions the other words
if you find a collision I'll show you a
way to break a size so that's well you
know I have to do something here right I
mean if if M is too small compared to n
this is not even compressing it so M has
to be larger than M is what des is the
description length of an element in the
domain has to be larger than the
description length of an element in the
range which is n times log your itís an
element turns that Q to the N so and
unlock you one has to be larger than the
other for compression so let's do it
right so M is larger when a lot larger
than n log Q and now turns out that this
guy is coalition or system why is that
suppose someone can find a collision co
r and r prime right a times R is equal
to a times R prime mod Q let's say now
or in our prime are both short what a
short there one vectors because that's
how I define my domain oh this is the
case what do I know I know that a times
R minus R prime is 0 mod Q so in other
words R minus R prime is a solution to
the Esaias problem for a I gave you a
matrix a you just found me r minus R
prime a short sis solution why is it
short because R and R prime have 0 1
entries therefore R minus R prime has 0
1 may be some minus 1 entries it's still
short compute the norm it's at most
square root of M square root of the
length very very simple so almost by
definition this problem actually gives
you a coalition to assist in dysfunction
a right so any any questions first piece
of crypto should be very excited all
right so this is it this coalition was
there for one - right
collision resistance implies one minute
so you're done so interestingly you know
this function we know about the hardness
even one veinous of this function only
for the range of parameters where it's
compressing all right so for coalition
resistance it only makes sense to talk
about compressing range of parameters I
mean otherwise what is what is coalition
resistance right but even the one Venus
of this object we only know for the for
the compressing range of parameters
right so there's something about sis
that is I don't know the hardness comes
from the fact that there are many
solutions and the hard thing is to kind
of pick out the the small one
is there any difference in terms of not
as far as I know not as far as I know I
mean the proof of one minute goes
through collision-resistant so you know
that's the that's the best profile good
okay so that is crypto from my situs my
most basic piece of cryptography now
let's see how hard is it sighs all right
so I I just assumed I told you a lot
about worst-case hardness of problems
lots of people studied you know SV psi
VP and so forth and they showed NP
hardness so on and so forth and here I
assumed an average case problem and
built crypto from it there is a
disconnect yes I mean how do i bridge
one one versus the other that's really
it's amazing amazing piece of work you
know I get goosebumps every time I think
about it you know is this really the
start of cryptography from from lattices
right so this is there a unique piece of
you know worst case average gates
connection that are not really
non-trivial worst case average case
connection that I know very nice
so what do I want to do what is what
does it mean worst case Travers case I
get I want to show reduction that that's
what it gets a lot of spaces gets any
lattice basis right long vectors I don't
really care and it maps it to two or
random as is instant I don't run the
matrix a that is an Esaias instance and
all right I do this I give it to you you
solve the Esaias problem what does that
mean you come up with the vector e I'm
changing notations a little bit I
realize so E and R I mean they're really
all less eius solutions for there for
the moment so what does it mean si a
solution is short and a times e is 0 mod
Q right so you come up with an sis
solution I'm going to find a short
vector in the lattice okay that's what I
want to do in fact I can I can do this
many times they can ask you for many sis
challenges it doesn't have to be a car
production it could be a Turing
reduction to be a cook reduction to
induction right of course this reduction
is randomized because I mean how am i I
mean I'm supposed to generate a random
instance what am I going to do so it has
to toss coins yes so that is what I want
to do this is the goal how do I take any
lattice basis and come up with one
distribution which is the uniform
distribution on matrices n by n matrices
such that if you solve this on the
uniform distribution on the average I
can find I can go back and find short
vectors on any letters right that's
really the the core here
so so one thing I didn't tell you which
I should have is so what is there what
is this big deal about - worst case
travellers case the reductions I mean
who who cares thank you
so the point is that you know factoring
right I mean what is the factoring
assumption why don't know I mean one
version of the factoring assumption is
says you pick two random primes of
length and equal size multiply them I
give it to you you give me the
factorization yes but why two primes why
not a prime of length and another prime
of length n plus you know 525 it's a
different assumption all of a sudden
maybe you can break one assumption but
not the other who knows what this gives
you is it gives you one assumption one
distribution that is as hard as any
other distribution you solve it you find
a worst-case solution so that really is
in other words the task of picking the
right distribution I don't have to worry
about it anymore this is the right
distribution beauty of this to me once
but how is it conceptually different
from suffer disability of discrete log
which is love discrete log you know as
much as you do maybe a little bit less I
don't know but look clearly less
careless but you know the a the the
software disability of discrete log base
a little bit bogus right I mean because
the question is which group I mean so
okay so I know how to pick in the
discrete log instance I pick at random G
and H at random right and that's good
enough how about the group where do I
come up with the group I pick a random
prime off like that I and that defines
the quadratic residue was ad group
something or elliptic curve you know I
have a fixed way of picking another
decarburization that's hard
how about another distribution articles
who knows
that's an assumption right no any a so
the reduction tells you what the right
cue is and if you solve it for this cue
you're you solve any shortest actor
problem this is not np-hard either
actually right so I mean I'd be very
happy if it were yes
point is that I can run once you run the
reduction
you know what the parameters are you
don't need to sort of a zoom hardness
for the worst case Q the worst case
group Thanks okay offline we'll fight it
out so let's do it okay so let's let's
show this worst case to average case
reduction Gaussian right now thank you
very much all right this is this is a
sort of a key character in our worst
case Travis case reduction and we'll use
gaussians in the you know the coins that
I toss will be essentially to pick
Gaussian distributions okay so this is a
Gaussian so is this and so is it in n
dimensions right I can define n
dimensional Gaussian distributions and
you know what I can also define other
things I can define by the way this is
thanks to a dad you know who knows how
to code apparently yeah so these are
gaussians but these are gaussians on
lattices so what does that mean I take a
Gaussian with a certain standard
deviation all right so that is the
number Sigma that comes out of this
probability density function and I plop
a Gaussian on each lattice point right
so what does that mean the probability
density at any point is a summation of
the density that comes from each lattice
point right so this is countably
infinite infinitely many lattice points
so it's not even clear that this is
well-defined but it is trust me and this
defines actually probability function
yes
just binary so how do you deal this
precision okay so this is against
something that I'm totally going to
ignore totally slip it under the rug but
I'm going to sort of divide the space
into sort of epsilon that's you know not
yes yes yes four four where the position
is polynomial in the end indeed
dimension so I have to be careful here
but okay so this is another Gaussian
just a little bit larger largest
standard deviation and this is yet
another Gaussian which is a little bit
larger standard deviation and quite soon
you see that this actually becomes a
flat distribution statistically close to
a uniform distribution once the standard
deviation becomes large enough and what
is large enough large enough
it's quantified by this beautiful lemma
of which aren't you on track F they call
it the smoothing lemma which says that
if I take a random lattice point this is
again I'm being very informal here what
does it mean a random lattice point you
know this point lattice point okay plus
sign I'm good a dust Gaussian with
standard deviation Sigma right which is
which is what I just did this gives you
something a distribution that is close
to uniform that is statistically close
to uniform as long as Sigma is larger
than the nth shortest length lambda M
the length of the end shortest vector of
the lattice you have to think about it a
little bit why is it lambda n you know
why why not lambda one okay well why
don't you just choose the Gaussian to be
to be larger than lambda one here's the
counter example here is a lattice right
the 1 lambda 2 so clearly if I choose
the Gaussian which is a ball really it's
radius lambda 1 I'm not going to I'm not
going to cover the entire space I'm not
gonna get uniform really the theorem
says as long as you you you you you
managed to choose it to be large enough
to be about the radius of this ball to
be about square root n times lambda n
you are going to cover the entire space
and in fact you're going to cover it
uniformly so you need something like
that to even reach there sort of the
deep hole there so the internal point of
the parallelepiped it says you know
that's the minimum thing that's that's
the sufficient thing so so this is this
doesn't depend on the basis it's an
invariant of the let's a lattice
invariant right so you I give you a
lattice that has a smoothing parameter
just like it has a short distractor the
same it's a it's a it's a quantity
associated to allow this okay so that's
scallions what do I do now five minutes
okay let's do the worst case a
prescription okay so here's the basis
this is what I get as input could
actually be pretty bad but I just you
know made life easier for me what am I
gonna do I have to generate many sort of
Esaias vectors right so how am I gonna
do it the first thing is I'm going to
divide the space into Q to the N
partitions this is an N dimensional
lattice right I can divide this is
essentially sort of take this vector
partition it into Q parts there's three
parts but in general Q so this is this
essentially defines a sub lattice of
rather super lattice of this original
lattice the first thing I do and that
tells me what Q is essentially right so
Q and there's no restriction on q q
doesn't define a sort of a hard problem
Q only has to be large enough anything
larger than a certain number is good
enough right that tells me you know
what's a you know it tells me you know a
lower bound on how fine great
- this divisionist is that's the first
thing I do so far so far so good
okay so I'm going to label lattice
points right this point is zero zero
this point is what is it zero one right
it depends on which corner of the sub
lattice it falls into right so all
points here if I take them their labels
are going to cover Q to the N right
right here oh that's a terrible idea
okay nevermind so this is 0-1 this is
0-2 like this is again zero zero because
it's a lattice point one zero one one go
on two and so on and so forth so covers
there are Q to the N many little dots
inside a parallelogram here and that
covers cute area okay let's start
sounding a little bit familiar now so
that's what do I want to generate I want
to generate Q - yeah point a vector from
Q to the N and here it is Q to the N now
what do I do
I'm going to pick a random lattice point
again random lattice point what does
that mean we want I'll conveniently slip
this under the rug there is a very nice
way of doing it
we'll talk about at the end random
lattice point okay what is the random
lattice point this is a random lattice
point once I pick a you know I set all
these things about gaussians why did I
say all these things oh my gosh means
because I'm gonna use them
I picked this random lattice point and I
add a Gaussian arrow a Gaussian sample
round in other words I pick a Gaussian
add it to this lattice point in other
words I am actually sampling from that
distribution with like many peaks that I
that I showed you that is what that is
now
let me make a simplifying assumption a
little bit of a simplifying assumption
which is that when I do this sampling it
actually falls at one of the corners of
this finer lattice right why would that
be probably won't but let me assume it
anyway okay just to make my life easier
so that is that's what that's what that
is
okay now this guy actually defines a
number a vector in Q to the N right
because I said remember each corner in
the final lattice can be labeled by a
number of by a vector from Q to the N
all right so that defines you know once
I get that a yellow point that defines a
number of vector and Q to the N I call
it a 1 all right that's the first column
of my Esaias matrix why stop here let me
do it again call it a to do again
independently at random call it a 3 so
on and so forth I do it M times a repeat
this process n times I am going to get
ma ice now the beautiful thing is that
if I choose my Gaussian to be large
enough how large lambda and about lambda
and this a is are distributed uniformly
at random because I just sampled from
the you know the plopped Gaussian
distribution it's a large enough
deviation which is random so it's going
to the probability that it's going to
land up in this corner is the same as
the probability it's going to land up at
this corner so it's uniformly random hey
I saw uniform d1 and guess what that is
my Esaias instance right my Esaias
instance is a which is a 1 up to am
where each of these guys is comes from
this sir this process so make sense ok
good so I just generated a random SAS
instance which is assuming that my MA
and the algorithm I have their saya
solver will refuse to work if I feed it
anything other than random ok so I
better do the right thing better feed it
a random Mac a size instance and that's
what I'm going to do and what is the
Oracle going to return to me it's going
to return a solution type probability
and so on and so forth and what is the
solution a short are write say plus
minus 1 0 because that's what I need
from the for the collision-resistant
hash all right so so I get some RI AI
vector is 0 mod Q that's what the Oracle
gives me that's right there
okay so now the question is what good is
it and now I'm supposed to find a short
vector in my original lattice question
is how do i how do I do it two minutes
don't let you off this is really the
monster you know
okay good so so let's sort of pick some
notation the eye is my lattice point why
I is what I is when I the sample that I
got by adding a Gaussian to it and ether
by is a short Gaussian the difference
between the two which is short right
that's what it is the key thing the most
important thing that comes out of this
reduction is the following I claim that
the sum of our I Y I is the lattice
vector is a vector and the original
lattice not this subdivided lattice and
that's the key because look at it the Y
eyes themselves are not in the lattice
right I mean that's the whole point and
they're not in the lattice but the dude
the SI a solver just gave me a way to
combine these Y eyes that plopped into
the lattice that landed up analyzed and
why is that the case well
well maybe I'll just
so what are these series wires right so
why eyes are lattice vectors with my
eyes are vectors in space where the
coefficient the coefficient when you
write it down in terms of the basis is
not an integer but an integer divided by
Q right because I just took the lattice
I scaled it down by Q so each why I is
RI times is B times some a what what we
call it Z I divided by Q that's what it
isn't Zi is an integer vector what did
this dude to just give me what did this
Oracle just give me he gave me a sum of
RI I mean so I just computed at some of
our iyi which is the sum of RI times
this now the point is if you look at the
sum of our I Zi this is I claim this is
zero mark you write that's exactly
because it's follows from the way I
defined the ice
and therefore this creature the some of
our is the I over Q is an integer rector
so this guy is a lattice vector this is
the key the key is that to use the
Esaias oracle to tell you how to combine
vectors that are not in the lattice and
produce the vector that is in the
lattice and that is it yes
well so the point is I want uniformity
in this in this so essentially what you
say it works right so I don't need to
sample a random lattice point I just
need to sample from Gaussian centered at
the origin because if you pick a lattice
point why not pick the origin and reduce
it modulo the parallelepiped right
that's good enough so what you're saying
is correct but I find it a little easier
to sort of think about random lattice
points add cows and so forth it is
exactly the way to actually do the proof
the CI over Q is the coefficient of Y I
right so right why I as B times
something right so I can always write
any vector in the space as B times
something and now I claim that because
this Y I lives in this subdivision of
the of the parallelepiped this something
B times that something is a multiple of
1 over Q ok that's that's how I actually
construct it right so so so this is like
1/3 2/3 so forth right so the claim is
that this is why I and when I write it
in the basis of B the coefficient is a
multiple of one working that's that's
the solid and and how did I construct my
AI that was essentially Z I mod Q right
I mean Zi is an integer vector take this
mod Q and that was my a I essentially
all right so let me just be more precise
so this is some RI B times Z is AI plus
Q times some integer vector Zi prime
over Q Q kind of cancels off with
release of no concern to me
the some of our ai ai over Q that's what
you just solved for me that is an
integer Ector
so put together this is B times some
integer vector which is the lattice
point yes too large I haven't gotten
there I haven't gotten there good
question right but you know the very
least I have a lattice point right if I
don't have it I might as well stop and
go home right okay so so what does that
mean the sum of R I Y I you know Y is B
plus E right the sum of R times V is the
sum of lattice points which is a lattice
point this is a lattice vector also this
lattice vector minus this lattice vector
is also a lattice vector right so bottom
line the sum of r IE i is a lattice
vector y is is good but it's sort of
large what is my what is the use for me
the point is i want to get a short guy
right and the point is that if i take
not the sum of Y eyes but the son of a
eyes that is also a lattice vector
because these guys differ a I and why
are I differ by a lattice point yes
since now I'm in business right so now
I'm back to your question this was a
lattice vector that was good but it's
not a short lattice vector it's
somewhere out there I don't like it
right I want to get here but if this is
a lattice vector this is also a lattice
vector and now I am in business so E I
are short vectors how long about lambda
N and R I saw an plus minus one so I'm
adding up about n of these guys so how
long can this be about n times lambda
and that's it good good good good
excellent good point good point so I you
know so I got a shot lattice vector so
I'm very happy again go home right but
what David is saying is what if it's
zero right I mean so you don't think
about it very often right but this is
this is a big problem
what if it's zero then I I ended up
doing all this work for nothing so I'm
not gonna say very much about it yeah
put this under technicalities you guys
actually figure out most of these things
already
you cannot sample a uniformly random
point all will actually work with not
with the lattice but essentially the
parallelepiped of the lattice which is
it's something that I can't sample from
David what if this is zero you can show
that this is not the case and really the
the key idea is that once I give you the
why I write the Gaussian is large enough
that there are many possible lattice
points where this could have come from
right so this is a pretty good lattice
point closed lattice point so is this
guy right I mean and you what you know
once I give you these why is essentially
once I give the SAS Oracle the wire is
it doesn't know where things are going
question earlier I think she suggested
just picking a fixed V and you know
taking dowsing samples from around that
V yes and I think if you did that then
this would fail this argument which
failed at the end about getting a
nonzero I think it's
don't think you need that it's really
the way to do it this it's not do a run
the blood despite and support with
really sample from the origin is the
center and reduce module the
parallelogram that that works okay so
finally you know I zoomed it's a big
assumption that when I sample from the
Gaussian I actually got points from this
final grid and this is never going to be
the case right so you have some sort of
a rounding you know an additional
rounding parameter which you have to
take care of and it'll make your
shortest vector not so shortest anymore
I can sort of add to this that's why you
need Q to be large enough so that this
this splitting this fineness is so large
that when you round you don't add too
much if Q is 2 then you're really adding
a lot to this so finally this is a
theorem that you can prove that you know
for any parameters and QM in beta with
some conditions so Q has to be large
enough you can reduce from worst case
approximate SIV P to within a factor or
something like this right so square root
n factor worse than the quality of the
solution that this is guy gives me so
you solve sis and you give me a vector
of length beta I am going to find you in
the lattice a vector of length in fact
many vectors linearly independent
vectors of length about beta times wrote
on what as beta have to be beta is
something like beta is the
a standard deviation of the Gaussian
which is about lambda n times square
root n the length of the vectors is
lambda n times square root n so you add
them up you're going to get something
like lambda n times n so the square root
and square it and add up you get a okay
so this is this is in fact the best we
know at this point right
in other words this is the best
approximation factor we know for the
hardness of a size okay the question is
you know so so Daniel asked if you can
do better if you can move crypto and all
the way to the left and that is as far
as I know still a very open question
okay so I did take a little bit longer
than I thought but not too much longer
so we'll move on later but this is you
can ask me questions you can grab me
during the break